on this week's show how to become
financially free through property in
2019 in the news house and ministers say
government will not step in to prevent
Airbnb and we're gonna be answering all
your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS I'm Alistair cutting on our welcome
to this week's property investors
podcast got a great show each of them
how you can become financially free and
great news for rent to renters yes
there's any one nation as well so yes
brilliant news on that front which we're
excited to bring to you have yet a good
week I've had an awesome week now my
heard I heard that you went out on
Friday night maybe and get crushed
haha yeah I samsung work parties yeah we
M so we were at the crash course in
Birmingham and we were it was actually
was it frightening it was Friday night
no not was Thursday night it was the
night before the crash but her star of
the night and so we we arrived at the
venue to set off and stuff at that I
went for a little swim we went out for a
meal and we got back to the hotel about
half-past nine 10 o'clock so we were all
gonna behave we all thought that nice
daily night could be fresh for the
morning but as you come into the hotel
you could hear like bang bang bang bang
bouncing bass music so our natural which
was it the room we used to do the crash
course it was the room right then the
very very massive room yeah so we m
really to just fold Oreos and just have
a look to see when the music was coming
from and it was a Samsung corporate
beach party and everyone in there what
was an employee of Samsung they all had
these little and these low lanyards with
like Samsung employee on there and
they're all they were in Beach gear and
stuff and were having a dance stuff and
the pettalia what the DJ was the best DJ
I've ever seen in my life they had like
saxophone players that dramas onstage
was it was the
- it was brilliant very good anyway so
there was security guards big beefed up
security guards on the door and so we
thought as never we're never gonna get
in there and I was with them Eliot Chris
jebin's and Ricky Mandel and I literally
said look guys it's all about confidence
so just walk in like just walk in like
we're supposed to be there and but
that's what we did we literally just
walked in they were supposed to be there
we didn't even get stopped once and we
were in there for like four hours and we
it was really quite funny it was a free
bar it's a free we woke up the bar so we
set a challenge amongst all four of us
that we all have to end we'll have to
leave with a lanyard so we have to
acquire a lanyard or something and we
all done that we all got lanyards just
being creative so we were on the dance
floor dancing and we were like hey I've
seen you before and all that and we'll
chat about and there's so many people
come up done goes oh yeah I've seen you
at the other conferences and things that
are and like people thought we actually
work for Samsung because it's all
different departments and you got your
iPhone and do you know what it was it
was awesome now it really was and then
we were at the bar right at the very
about one o'clock in the morning half
one we're at the bar and then we're
trying to get some more drinks and but
they shot the shot that sort of free bar
at this point and you a lot forget this
yeah pain and then there was a guy stood
next to us and he was a little bit
suspicious and then he's he goes oh he
was talking to Ricky and you know what
it's like when you asked Ricky a direct
question he goes on so it's like a deer
in headlights he can't answer so he was
um he was chatting to Ricky he said what
branch do you work in and Ricky was like
same as you man I walk in the same
department as you and he goes well what
were three people and I don't recognize
you then the guy says do you work for
Samsung and Rick went have a nice day he
just walked off and then he went on in
the bar and a guy got security and then
really looked out we didn't get kicked
out but we saw some cutie comments a
girl just left but we had for our Sweden
have four hours of like phenomenal party
free bar brilliant DJ like one of the
best DJs I've ever
been in presence of all court stuff
Samsung you should be better off saying
that you're these you were the light
look-alike you brought younger David
Brent look-alike David Brent come on
really gonna be that on the allergy
nobody was busting the moves and dance
floor we were like I hate man all the
people loved us a little bit sounds
great what did you go up to well you
took up all the times are now to talk
i'll tell people next week let's talk
about becoming financially free and
property then alright perfect so i
suppose first of all before you can talk
about how to become fancy for
financially free yep what is what does
it mean if i I know so financially free
does not mean rich it does not mean you
are a millionaire it does not mean that
you are living an abundant life it means
that your passive income which is income
that comes to you whether you work or
not
yeah covers your living expenses so your
passive income yeah is equal to or
greater than your basic living expenses
Samuel sums it up that's that's pretty
passive income great they're very good
to your base you live experiment
misconception is that been obviously
samuel was financial 321 was a great and
everyone seems to think like he was
walking around and they could bentley
and living this lifestyle of a culture
yeah he was in a dacha when he banged up
all that job was a brand-new one but
still a dacha there's a brand new like
they're like five five grand five grand
but point being is everyone thinks it
when you see you're financially free
you're like living this lifestyle of a
multi Munez that's not the case it's
just you're living within your means and
your passive income covers that so one
of the easiest so what if i have the
difference active income versus passive
income okay you got one minute you go
active income you go to work nine to
five you're actively working to make
that income passive income you do the
job once
so you set up something once and then
you get paid for it time and time again
prior brewing example as property but i
like for me one of my passive income
streams is my book hmm so i wrote
whatever it takes once and it brings me
income every single month every month
and i do nothing for it
nothing so that's a brilliant stream of
passive income
we're talking about property I've got
properties that make passive income as
well so property is what wouldn't be
talking about so that's it one minute
brilliant so financially for a you need
passive income yeah so I mean properties
obviously one yeah but was a property
investors podcast but what wouldn't so
you've obviously mentioned the book what
whatever what other areas are that you
can think of your proxy don't property
it's a property any sort of royalties
from any sort of literature you write
share us if you've got shares in
anything any another business or if
you've got sort of shares and a company
on the stock market if you've got any
any sort of assets which increase in
value and bring your own income in the
stock market though it's you don't get
the money out do you just sort of you
can well you can do you can buy today
leave it and you can put some faster
than those it's passive this is if
you're buying okay if you're acting it's
right hey it depends it depends how you
do it if you buy if you buy shares in
Google they go up in value but yeah
they're not paying your monthly no
they're not paying your monthly so in
passive income that would you're right
actually that's that's correct it
wouldn't give you passive income because
you're not getting cash for monthly and
so if you were to answer you're a trader
in your trader this what properties it's
a great investment because you get ice
yeah you get paid cash flow and you get
ice on Sammy Wilson Bitcoin yeah yes
what's happened to that well it did it's
now gone up again now I was back to
about what he paid for it mother
the but my point is with with property
you've got you've got you've got both to
lots of payments most stuff you don't
get that however pays your monthly but
depreciates yeah so for example if you
bought a car and rented it out you get
monthly payment from it but the asset
would depreciate or both I can't think
of anything else energy boat I'm sure
there are if you know it behaves you
twice let me know but I can't talk my
hair to go isn't it if you've got a
business is profitable and it's that's
growing like for instance a fennel yeah
like like you know me in our business is
growing monthly monthly money it's worth
more and it's also giving us a much yes
I mean a good business but like any
investment there's risk we're
entrepreneurs at the end of them what's
the definition of an entrepreneur
do you know what is yeah what was a it's
someone who takes risks in order for
financial gain basically it's a risk
taker this prepared state risk for
financial gain
so like any business we're entrepreneurs
we're prepared to take risks if we're
high high reward you need risk for a
reward you can't have no risk and expect
all the rewards so property goes up
property goes down gold goes up gold
because then everything goes up and goes
down you just have to make sure you pick
the right asset we believe property is
the right asset which I genuinely do my
properties bring me a rental income
every month and do you know what I don't
even even seen half my home ain't even
seen any of my houses now I saw them I
saw two of them when I first bought one
but I've not seen the other ones so I
saw Wolverhampton in Hull when I first
bought one I've never been back to Hall
and all the works been done it's
bringing it's bringing me 13 under par a
month Wolverhampton bringing me 16 under
plan a month and I don't see it
I'm nothing to do with it yeah it's gone
up in value and it's getting I'm getting
paid for it every month so see we've
business I believe you can create a
passive income through through a
business yeah I believe you can but I
think that you're a lot more likely to
be involved and for a lot longer yeah
well if you're setting up a new business
give me a while before unless you've got
a lot of money to invest in a higher
people and partners if we invested in
like a really high-end massive like like
fortune 500 or whatever company where
they like Apple for instance bung
underground into Apple you get paid a
dividend and you get the the increase in
the share price so you wouldn't be
involved in that with you you can't be
like going into the Apple top too late
man I'm your boss would you even even
know who you are
no because when you invest in them
companies they've already got the
infrastructure in place they're doing
all the donkey work yeah
so that's passive and you're going to
get past an income from that through
dividend and you're also gonna get let
me tell you the big difference Wade you
know you said yes they're gonna pin it
in value and they're paying your monthly
I think there's a much bigger risk that
they won't go up in value compared to a
property with property you're pretty
much guaranteed over long term yeah
might now we got brexit come in here
might you know you might have a bit of a
dip you missed
that we historically will go on yeah
whereas businesses historically they
don't want you in the recession but not
just that like if you look at so for
example Canton with the exact stats but
if you look at the the fortune 500
companies from 50 years ago most of them
are no longer they're different and they
think the top two or three or still be
there but the rest I'm all different so
chances are you invest in coming out 50
years chances are that company no no
so is mariahs its property I think
probably is easy list okay so we know
what financially free is so the first
this to just suppose there's two things
need to work out the first thing you
need to work out is how much do I
actually need to be financially free
yeah
well out there a property investors
crash course we do our whole session on
like defining your financial freedom
figure and making it is achievable as
possible and what is the easiest way to
make your financial freedom figure as
achievable as possible is well you need
to know your bet you need to know what
you could live on the basic course and
that's not you need to cut back you need
to look at your bank statement and look
at your outgoings and say look what do I
not need and I can still survive and one
of the easiest ways to do that you know
is go through your direct debits and
just I've done this and just cancel them
all just cancel the ones that you know
you don't know what for now I'm not
seeing growing cancer your mortgage
payments and cancer your insurance is
not so stop I'm just saying if you've
got a direct debit you don't know what
it is we've all got long well we've all
had them just cancel it if it's
important the company will get in touch
with you and then you can make an
assessment actually have to earn eat
that dating app or do a play of animal
sure sure it is true yeah like I mean do
I worry yeah yeah do you need all these
things that you like God like Netflix I
had three Netflix accounts got Netflix
accounts Spotify what to Spotify
accounts what I don't know you tell me
because probably I forgot my passport
and passport that's you know good you
can have a little thumbnail of a
passport at that point no
probably I forgot my password and I
scream the board trying to find it so I
just set up a new account that's the
reality of what probably happened
so I've got $7.99 and 79 coming out of
my bank twice right and then it's even
Netflix I have three Netflix accounts
okay so the first thing need to know is
I have what you're basically in expenses
so then you know how much will you need
to make in passive income and need to
come up with ways of doing it we saw
that simplify cyma cause that simplified
the course to simplify your expenses
yeah so you need to find out what
expenses are and then you need to work
out the way so what would you say right
now 2019 best things to invest in to
give you good cash flow because this is
all about cash flow now isn't it
yeah it's become finally freely good
capacitive income that's good cash flow
so this example deals that source in
wouldn't work unless you make it into a
business where it's passive but
initially for like if you're just
starting out you're a good couple of
years away from making it passive yeah
took me two years I took more you didn't
mean you and I have to get it passive
rent to rent isn't really not really a
renter into active is so active so you
say maybe HMOs might be a good good
teacher more with a good hitch more
manager and again it comes back to how
much money you've got to invest yeah so
if you've got a balance if you've got
money in your bank to invest I would go
do you know what I would go high-end HM
or six seven eight bedrooms or even even
a slightly slightly bigger or maybe like
rent to rent hey Tomo if you haven't got
much money yeah that's what you can get
to so you've got that's the money if
you've got money go high-end hitch em
all good hit good location good hit you
more manager make it as hands-free as
possible so you're not involved with it
and that's going to give you a good
rental income and or if you haven't got
any money the same again
high-end HMO but on like some sort of
rent to rent strategy or some sort of
agreement maybe a lease auction or
something with the landlord and
obviously that the latter's gonna be
harder to find and more difficult to
secure but that's where education comes
in mmm if you're educated correctly and
then you can do both strategies yeah
it's very easy to go out if you've got
money and invest in property yeah
it's easy it's not difficult as a all
lease options yeah it's a lease option
agreement to rent lease options you need
you you need the education for
everything okay but let's just face it
there if you're coming into this with
money it's that little bit easier
because
have to yeah well you've got work out
the figures when we would do our Academy
obviously the goal with the academies if
them to become financially free yeah
that's it and the figure that we kind of
have in minds in our minds he's about
two and a half grand a month yeah that's
the target because some people say they
need five grand a month it's like come
on really you know do you remember that
dude it stood up at the crash course
couple weeks ago and we said we asked
him what is financial freedom figure
wasn't he said thirty grand a month to
beat you there yeah hey come on man it's
just crazy that was that was his
ultimate financial freedom no that
wasn't it wasn't that was his salmon
last him what's your financial if he
knows someone else then and you said
it's 30 grand a month and Sam said come
on I wasn't there I didn't see it's not
earning that now so how could that be
his financial freedom figure because if
he is he's he's he's gonna day every
single month no that's what he wants to
achieve yeah see this confusion isn't it
people most people like when you see
what's the average salary in the UK
about 27 around I was gonna say 27 28
grand what would that board that give
you as a take-home salary take-home yeah
so Nick 27 grand so 24 grands two grand
a month you'll take home about twelve
thirteen hundred so I don't know maybe
it's prob about t comma but fifteen
sixteen hundred pound a month you bit
more research to find a quick look yeah
all right
so well you make you a point being is
the average salary is twenty seven
twenty eight thousand pounds a year and
in the UK no there was people are more
those people unless but for some date
you see yes something my FF figures five
grand a month when they're not earning
that of the minute it's not true so it's
just a case of 1825 so there are basalt
teacups I was eighteen hundred quid a
month twenty twenty twenty-one an hour
so that's your financial freedom figure
at least that's that's there because
that's all that's what you're earning at
the minute now if you still pay tax on
your property stuff as well yeah so that
would be at a course of a natural
freedom yeah yeah now obviously we all
want more of course we want more that's
why we do what we do that's why
everyone's in business that's why we go
to these events that's why we tried to
create more income streams but you could
live off that that's all your visor and
live off that and the brilliant thing
about becoming financially free I've
done it you've done it many of us have
done it is once you become financial
Fenian not the pain
then on somebody to like a job to pay
your wages what does that give you in
the world there was the one that it
gives you the one thing you cannot
replace what is the freedom freedom time
well freedom same thing in it you got
freedoms up time yeah sort of okay you
know I know you were going for the all
Scottish freedom thing but oh no ok wait
yeah he shoes all right
[Music]
freedom but it gives you time and when
you've got time you can grow your
financial freedom poll it's your time
because you've got time cuz oh what's
one of the biggest objections we hear
from people about why they can't get
involved in what we do like yet I
haven't got time and work time is money
man
exactly time is money time working and
working ain't got time to waste any more
right it's now time for this
[Music]
in the news this week we're talking
about some positive for once we get news
on today unless you run a hotel well
yeah it's even now you have to make it
negative doesn't name what is it with
you right here we go this is the
headline Housing Minister says
government will not act to regulate
Airbnb Minister has told Parliament's
the new the new that the government
supports new business models despite
worries Airbnb is best wedding landlord
to exit traditional lettings Housing
Minister Kip Malthouse has waded into
the ongoing debate over the rapid
expansion of Airbnb in the UK by
confirming that the government supports
new business models and the economic
benefits that they can bring he told
Parliament yesterday so in other words
right now the government is supporting
Airbnb and Wales and serviced
accommodation it's M it's it's news it's
been long overdue I think because their
lot could have been worrying about it I
however still don't believe it he said
well what he did say said he said that
all landlords who let accommodation on a
short-term basis must do so responsibly
and in accordance with the law yeah
that's just that's just the government's
get that's the government sort of them
caveat to them saying you can do isn't
it that doesn't actually mean anything
because we see that with everything I'm
saying to see if you won't be a landlord
you've got to do it responsibly but how
do they enforce it because they don't do
they yeah so I think this is good news
for time for a short term I do think
however it's not going to last I think
in a couple years time will be massive
regulation on it it'll come through that
kitchen walls but anyway I mean it's
good for short-term so as the far more
say make hay while the Sun shines
yep so go for it yeah we often talk
about when they get a change it will
change at some point but I mean the
government can change what they say they
say one thing one day you see that when
they're up for election we're gonna do
this we're gonna do this and then soon
as we get it just like oh yeah you
remember the just remember the NHS
didn't they do that it breaks it with
all boss there's 350 million a day on
anything they do it do one thing that I
went out like though is all the they're
like yeah we're spending this much on on
this you know do you want
Lexie or NHS or do you want H s2 or NHS
do you not we see comment both both yeah
what do you why is it one or the other
do you remember a link it was coming up
for the bricks at elections and
literally at Nigel arrived was going on
about he was being very very like are we
spend all this money on the HS of day
and literally I got twenty minutes after
the results he was interviewed on BBC
Breakfast News and he completely
contradicted everything that said
because the reporter said to him what
brothers three hundred and fifty million
you said this and any completely
backtracked on it is once the results
come out and it was the most awkward was
the most open and eye-opening interview
I've ever seen with the politician well
just goes to show most politicians are
full of complete BS maybe I hurt you
heard it here first
well I think they already I've known
that yeah it's a shocker is it not much
of a shocking news statement is it but
there you go good news for now on the
whole service combination air B&B front
right it's now time for your questions
and our answers
[Music]
okay so the first question that's come
out by the way before I actually go into
that if you want your questions answered
best place to go is the property
investors with Samuel Leeds Facebook
group we do a Facebook live before we
start filming and that is where that's
where we get all these questions from so
just go and check out that group just
join become member yep and you know
we're there to answer your questions
guys so it's the first question from max
Stuart what's the best way to find
sellers in regards to property sourcing
I'm assuming he means directive end or
seller's mmm well he doesn't say that so
right move right move yeah biggest
source of sellers in the country my
friend if you want directive Endor then
you have to go start getting creative if
you've been to the crash course we do
talk a little bit about that we
certainly cover that a lot at the deal
fund and extravaganza and the never
usual money don't they never used your
own money again course so yeah there's
great waste there's many many ways to do
it
give them one directive vendor letters
letters so let's send in letters - hot -
hot leads or tired landlords absolutely
awesome thank you I hope that answers
your question max next question from
Braden Maybury hi guys just went to the
crash course and loved it thanks for
your time no problem or worries man in
regards to lease option agreement what's
the best way to get the contact details
of the property owner so you don't have
to go through an estate agent Land
Registry three-pound you can get details
of the homeowner and Land Registry or it
depends how you're finding your leads if
they're on a state agent and you you're
gonna have to get very creative because
you struggle to find them also when you
do go to Land Registry it's likely if if
they live there I heard a brilliant tip
a brilliant tip for how to do this right
so what you do you get a view of the
estate agent normal I know this is going
you get these magnetic hey somebody else
said that was a good tip as well right
you go in the house do the viewing a
certain age ain't looking stay on the
fridge and then you wait for them to
call the person that broke into their
home and put a fridge my fridge no yes
you know people do that and it's
to me just so just get get creative you
don't do a viewing and also get friendly
with the state agents do you know you
don't have to cop in a state agent out
it sounds to me that you're trying to
save a bit of money in trying to cut on
a state agent out of the deal go to an
estate agent get friendly with in the
stage and say look this is what you want
to do if it works and if we get to go if
we get to complete on the deal the
estate agent still sold your house so
just pay the fee don't cut them out
because think about this right if you go
if you get friendly with an estate agent
right and they give you a property which
you then turn into a lease option
agreement they still give you the lead
so at the end of this only fear to pay
them but where do you think they're
gonna go next time they have a property
that might work for a lease option
agreement do you think they're gonna
come to you who tried to cut them out or
do you think they're going to go to one
of the other investors that said you
know what I'll happily pay your fee so
don't be too stingy and don't cut your
nose off to spite your face every lease
option agreement I've done to an estate
agent I have paid the stage in the fee
so just be in have your integrity be
upfront about it and just pay the state
agent the fee and you'll get a much
better relationship I say this all the
time property is about people it's not
about property here's a linked question
then link links right based on what you
just saying that today so this is from
Steven Jobson how do you get an agent to
put you in contact with a landlord
direct what does a story about when
you've done it comes down to
relationships it's relationships or but
what you've done it gives an example
okay on YouTube there's a video of me
and Simon like one of my properties in
Hull maybe Nick can put a link making
put a link thank you very much and
that's a property that I sauce on our I
secured on a lease option agreement it
was on with a an agent in Hull and it
fell through because there were a naked
victory and they couldn't pay the
mortgage balance and basically if we can
put the video on that kind of answers it
but you you got food from the agent
you're going the video doesn't really
talk a much about how I secured it so
I'll just briefly go into that oh I am
an old you want to have a lot a nap or
something on you sounded a bit bored
dude every time you'll speak in so I'll
plow in I'll last or last maybe
get me a coffee just to keep me going
okay right cool right so a state agent
told me it falling through I then said
this agent look can I have the details
of the barrels because I can still I can
still proceed
they wouldn't they obviously and this
pen they wouldn't do it because they
didn't know who I was they didn't know
like Oh trust me and so I then got
really creative and I started looking
for that property and all the rental
channels and various other channels
online of where you would sale or rent a
property and I happen to find an old
link or for the property when it was for
available for rent and I contacted that
agent and said look I'm interested in
buying this house can you please forward
this my contact details to the people
who own the house and about two three
weeks later I got an email from the
people who own the house
so on Matt that instance it worked it's
not growing even example of my wives and
again it's not being creative so I saw a
property up for sale
mm-hm and I could tell immediately that
it used to be HMI had fire doors on
every room was a bedroom you know the
time you can tell so I thought hmm looks
on spare-room found and all that with
the pictures ranked rang them up it's
the landlord putting it on direct so
let's try hold and unload that way
there's so many creative ways you just
got to get creative and like we're
actually we're actually filming this
this event at one of our follow at Lance
training events called a deal found and
extravaganza this is what they're doing
downstairs guys they are we're up here
filming this downstairs they're finding
director vendor leads with houses our
potentials for lease options director
vendor rent rent HMOs all sorts so there
is a bit of creativity knee got to get
creative brilliant you do one more yes
I've got one here go on hit me up okay
so
okay Lauren Micaiah McGuire what if you
have been offered a really good deal
hate to more lease option in an era you
aren't you of it's very nice thank you
I hate summer least opportunity short in
an area not sure it's very nice what
would you do first of all I check if it
ticked at the boxes don't become a
motivated by on but you don't want to
turn now opportunity and not saying oh I
didn't say turn it down I said don't
come motivate buyer Anna so just because
it's a free house or a low money down
house does not mean you should take it
needs to check the area
so let's don't just go for it but she's
good she's doing that already but she's
asking us on it so first thing you need
to do is check it ticks the five boxes
yep
remember what they're in five boxes all
I do but if we got a video for that we
could put a link up for as well yeah
right brilliant so we'll stick a video
up tape tell you what the five tip books
I think we've talked about on this show
as well then once you've checked that
that ring some hey Chabot managers in
the area and say hey I'm looking at a
house in XY street would you be able to
rent that out for me and what it sort of
rents to expect and then ring a few and
just to get feedback don't think just
cause the lease option you're not buying
you are buying you're committing to buy
in five years time I know you've got an
option but you are committing you're
seeing Luke in five years I was planning
on buying you're planning on committing
but flying away about but you you've got
that option to buy a fabulous time you
still buy in a property so it's treat it
like you're a buy too late like you're
still buying a product or a good proper
to do all your due diligence and then if
if it's not for you and it's a lease
option and you have an investor perhaps
it's not an eery you like for instance
then maybe there's an investor that does
like that area see if they want to take
off your hand things it doesn't have to
be a nice area just has to be a
profitable area hmm that's that's
actually a very good bit of advice and I
I do get this a lot a lot of investors
who live in like a nice leafy nice part
of cane or rubber the nice big four or
five bedroom house and then they see a
woman deliver so well that beckons field
or somewhere awesome yeah yeah yeah and
then the right okay so they live in a
really nice area but they must also know
then you say to them look why don't you
have take an investment property
in like I don't know Preston and they
will don't like Preston oh I don't know
Preston so they drive up to Preston and
they see that it's maybe not as nice is
where they come from it doesn't matter
because they are not going to live there
the people that live there will live
they are and they are they're
comfortable and that surrounding so
that's their that's the problem so
that's the good thing so don't just
stick to your area because you live in a
nice area do you get me I dig you man
you dig me I'd dig yep right guys thanks
ever so much for watching this show
we'll be back next Saturday at 7 p.m.
look forward to you there and please
subscribe to the channel you haven't
already see you next week see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]